laughs homes and the you claim within
this bilateral relationship there's a
really rich theme of Education
Corporation unreal and each other's
languages France and England have
recognized the opportunity to do more to
help learning languages and here there
are some real opportunities to
collaborate
so let's dare try new things a recent
report in France suggests that it's
about learning to have more fun being
more audacious and starting young
thinkers teaching through English
animation is gaining momentum
internationally with our UK partners
we've been working to train up to 350
teachers and head teachers from the
Paris region it's just a start but
listen to this feedback
impressible Varanasi experiences
national a document a city la formación
aliphatic officially z-coil ligado
guarantee professor physical benefits
beyond ominous nerve to information and
immersion Odion only perform at her look
at her native to British concern in the
Versailles area some preschools were
included in the training he said to me
in my love affair middle of work come on
auntie lizhen for they mock practically
on class management of general DePaul
experiment at a hobby nakida Maha de la
petite section of the meta and look for
the formation appear me accept avocado
senior this reform a porno Sangju
harnessing it are lonely at the same
time the Department for Education
recently launched a new fund to
encourage English schools to build
international partnerships ultimately
it's about letting the students and the
generations of tomorrow dare to try
something different on an ad the roller
sweet